[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec violaine dira un médecin
endocrinologue vous êtes membre du
collectif laissons les médecins à
prescrire bonsoir violaine guerra merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous à vos côtés
bruno m'égare ban chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bonsoir à bruno mégarde merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
le conseil de l'ordre qui a donc décidé
poursuit didier rahout c'est tout de
même une procédure disciplinaire c'est
pas rien violaine des reins c'est une
procédure disciplinaire mais en fonction
de l'article 5 du code de déontologie
article r 41 35 5 du code de santé
publique
nul ne peut être y est née la dépendance
professionnels d'un médecin donc
monsieur raoult tafer des communications
sur des recherches qu'il a fait je vois
difficilement le conseil de l'ordre
pouvoir le condamner à ce sujet et
j'ajoute même que du moment où son
action n'a occasionné aucun dommage et
que au contraire
l'abstention est responsable d'une perte
de chance ce n'est peut-être pas le
professeur raoul tki qui va être embêté
par cette procédure mais ceux qui
prétendent l'empêcher d'agir
et contrairement à ce qui a été dit dans
votre documentaire il y a énormément de
publication au niveau mondial qui ont
montré qu'en phase précoce de traitement
les associations et donc si coquine
azithromycine était non seulement bien
toléré mais également avait apporté des
bénéfices aux personnes qui avaient été
traitées ainsi et je peux d'autant plus
en témoigner que nous mêmes le collectif
laissons les médecins prescrira font
travailler avec les médecins qui étaient
malades au mois de mars
février mars avril puisqu'il y avait
beaucoup de médecins généralistes qui
était malade et qui ont souhaité suivre
ce protocole et nous avons publié
également ces données au niveau
international donc c'est très important
d'être très vigilants aussi sur ce que
vous dites dans vos reportages parce
qu'il y a ce qui s'est passé on va dire
en ville ou en traitement de phase
précoce et puis ce qui s'est passé
également dans les réanimations à des
stades beaucoup plus tardif et on sait
très bien que ce sont des stades de la
maladie qui sont différentes donc il
faut être extrêmement vigilant sur ce
que l'on dit non c'est vrai qu'il ya
aussi de nombreux responsables français
notamment politiques qui sont exprimés
dans de nombreux médias en
décrédibilisant ce traitement hydroxyque
europe qui nous avait bien raison parce
que c'était précisément ma prochaine
question j'ai pris la peine d'aller
regarder avant cette émission la carte
des pays qui recommandait l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et c'est assez
impressionnant la carte se colore avec
plein de pays pas les moindres la moitié
des etats-unis les pays-bas l'iran la
chine le maroc la tunisie
j'en passe la russie qui recommandait
qui utilisent justement cette molécule
alors qu'on semble diaboliser le
professeur raoul qu'en france parce que
précisément ils utilisent bruno m'égare
balle ça vous inspire quoi justement
vous en tant que médecin pourquoi des
pays et pas les moins quand même pas les
plus sous-développées utilisent cette
molécule est le professeur ruth est
diabolisé pour cela dans notre pays
alors tout d'abord je ne crois pas que
l'essentiel des plaintes qui ont été
formulées auprès de l'ordre des médecins
concerne l'utilisation de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine je crois que effectivement
le processeur out a une intuition
extrêmement sens et au départ basé
d'ailleurs sur des travaux qu'il a fait
lui même sur l'efficacité in vitro de
l'hydre aussi chloroquine pour stopper
la réplication virale et ensuite
effectivement basé sur son expérience
très large et reconnu internationalement
comme infectiologues
il a souhaité utiliser ce traitement
chez les patients qui présentaient la
lakovic 19 à un moment où bien sûr on
n'avait pas d'autre thérapeutique
d'autres alternatives thérapeutiques
donc on va dire sa démarche scientifique
initiale était tout à fait louable
après ce que ce qui lui a été reprochée
c'est de persister dans l'affirmation
que l'hydroxyde chloroquine et efficace
alors qu'effectivement ça cumulé un
certain nombre d'arguments scientifiques
qui on va dire démontrez l' inverse
malgré tout je ne crois pas que à
nouveau que ça soit le sujet de la
plainte de l'ordre des médecins je
croise chaque médecin a le droit de dire
que tel traitement efficace ou tel autre
ne l'est pas en fonction de son
expérience personnelle je crois qu
essentiellement on l'appela la plainte
porte sur des histoires de violation de
confraternité et d'éventuellement
d'informations erronées du public
mais pour ma part plutôt sur le on va
dire l'absence de dangerosité de la
corona virus qui pourrait plus posé on
va dire question on cherche quand même à
décridibiliser d'une certaine manière le
professeur raoul puisqu'on on le
poursuit aussi pour charlatanisme c'est
pas rien quand même pour un professeur
de médecine
wehrling guérin pour vous c'est
finalement la personnalité du docteur
raul qui est en jeu où on règle ses
comptes entre médecins finalement
puisque bonhommes et garonne le le
rappeler c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des mots
envers les des confrères pas toujours
très gentille c'est sûr on va déjà aussi
dire qu'il ya eu beaucoup de mots très
désagréable vis-à-vis de monsieur raoul
tu et que les médecins qui ont proféré
ces mots n'ont même pas été inquiété du
tout parce que c'était 2-2 très agressif
et même très incorrect
moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
monsieur raoul ce bond a fait ses
recherches effectivement une vitre
ouattara moi en tant que médecin quand
j'ai dû m'occuper de mes confrères bon
bien entendu j'ai entendu monsieur raoul
près connu une fin des préconisations
mais ce que j'ai fait surtout géré près
toute la littérature chinoise
j'ai repris aussi la littérature du ca
d'un épisode du strass dussart score 1
et j'ai bien
noté l'intérêt des chinois que ce soit
pour la chloroquine pour l'hydro xi
chloroquine les avaient traités avec
différentes molécules
mais c'est en reprenant cette
bibliographie là que je me suis fait mon
idée aussi et que j'ai essayé aussi les
recommandations du professeur depuis ce
qu'elle faisait ça quand on avait repris
toute la bibliographie dussart score 1
et y compris de la manière dont la
pathologie
le strass se présentait et on avait déjà
énormément d'informations finalement par
exemple par rapport à ce type de deux
pathologies virales et des atteintes
pulmonaires donc dire que monsieur
raoult peut-être un charlatan autre bon
de toutes ces choses non au strictement
aucun sens et ce qui est très inquiétant
c'est que c'est tout à fait anormal ce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est normal
parce que on pourra voir moi publié
beaucoup dans le passé on peut ne pas
être d'accord entre confrères on discute
on va des congrès on échange mais on
n'est pas dans un niveau de violence tel
qu'on l'a vue actuellement et dans des
niveaux de d'anomalies sur les
publications le land fait guette des
choses comme ça c'est du jamais vu enfin
moi moi moi j'ai 60 ans et donc j'ai
publié quand j'étais beaucoup plus jeune
et à un moment où il y avait sans doute
beaucoup moins de conflits d'intérêt
partout et qui aujourd'hui la crise
elle révèle justement des conflits
d'intérêts elle révèle des querelles
des historiques aussi de querelles
peut-être mais moi je suis navré parce
qu'on oublie les patients dans tout ça
et ça augmente beaucoup de langues ouest
des gens même les médecins sont perdus
les médecins reçoivent des injonctions
de la rs de la direction générale de la
santé par rapport aux prescriptions mais
c'est ça aussi c'est du jamais vu
les médecins généralistes aujourd'hui
qu'ils reçoivent en ville des
interdictions prescrire de l'asie trop
micinn sur des les pathologies des
surinfections pulmonaires ou des
pathologies pulmonaires ou des tableaux
de présentation pulmonaire alors que
cette classe de médicaments les
macrolides et est vraiment une place
intéressante pour traiter les patients
aujourd'hui les médecins généralistes
ont encore reçu des messages comme quoi
fallait encourager de télémédecine
mais ça c'est du grand n'importe quoi on
les patients on les examine en les
ausculte pourquoi il ya eu beaucoup de
morts parce qu'il ya aussi des gens on
n'a pas examiné on a laissé continuer de
se dégrader chez eux
et là on a changé complètement les
circuits habituels du soin ce qui n'est
pas du tout normal
en tout cas la principale critique et
vous aujourd'hui de l'avocat en lui même
de guider raul tu m fabrice division
très remonté contre le conseil de
l'ordre des médecins on écoute l'ordre
n'a rien fait depuis le début il ya des
médecins qui sont morts
café l'ordre rien les médecins manquent
et de masques et de ffp2 café l'ordre
rien mais que fait l'ordre il n'a
poursuivi que les médecins qui ont
utilisé de l'hydroxyde chloroquine est
ce que l'ordre a réagi aux rênes d y
virent non un prénommé garvan à votre
réaction
mais écoutez je trouve qu'on mélange
beaucoup de choses je vois pas quel est
le rapport entre l'hydroxyde chloroquine
les masques et le remdh et sévir
donc effectivement les drogueries
chloroquine a été promu au départ par
monsieur raoul t par d'autres moi même
je l' ai prescrit à une cinquantaine de
patients lors du premier pic épidémique
nous nous sommes rendu compte au travers
de nos observations mais également au
travers d'études randomisées que
heureusement ça ne marchait pas on
aurait tous souhaité évidemment que ce
soit parfaitement efficace et donc on a
arrêté le prescrire maintenant
évidemment je suis d'accord avec ma
consoeur moi je n'aurais pas je n'aurai
pas promu une interdiction par les
autorités sanitaires
j'aurais plutôt préféré des
recommandations de bon usage
on voit bien effectivement que cette
affaire a tourné un peu à la folie
quelque part et là on mélange avec leur
mdc dire qui n'a rien à voir quelqu'un
autre traitement antiviral qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas davantage montré
d'efficacité plus probante
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui nous ne le
prescrive on pas y compris pour les
patients les plus graves en réanimation
parce que très probablement son
efficacité versus série ce que n'est pas
très favorable donc c'est pas parce que
l'on prescrit pas que l'on n'adhère pas
à l'idée que les drogues cyclo routine
et efficace que l'on ait nécessairement
un suppôt du laboratoire gilead qui
promeut et qui vend le rêve des civils
pour ma part je suis totalement neutre
je regarde uniquement les arguments
scientifiques mais aujourd'hui je le
prescrit ni l'hydroxyte leur hockey ni
leur md sévir al'inverse les masques
peut-on parfaitement prouvées un intérêt
préventif et donc je porte le masque
soignants tous les jours des tas de
patients infectés par l'aco vide
je peux vous rassurer je ne l'est pas
attraper grâce à ses moyens de
prévention en tout cas contraire fait
réentendre un didier rahout principal
sujet de conversation c'était le 30
avril dernier lors de la première vague
et déjà ses prises de paroles agacé
écouter ce que lui on pense je peux dire
ce que je fais j'ai bien droit le dire
j'ai le droit de m'exprimer
scientifiquement les universitaires ont
une liberté de parole qui est inscrite
dans la constitution
personne ne peut toucher ça et la
question est est ce qu'il ya vraiment
une liberté de parole pour les
scientifiques avionnais nogueira
m'écouter théoriquement il ya une
liberté de parole un mois je la prends
aussi et je confirme
j'ai traité des patients avec ce
protocole et en particulier des médecins
et que ça s'est bien passé en phase
précoce la différence de mon confrère
monsieur mes gars ben moi je suis en
ville donc je vois les patients tôt et
monsieur mes gars banal une expérience
en réanimation qui sont des expériences
totalement différente et je l'entends
bien quand il dit que son expérience
n'est pas positiver et je veux bien
croire
simplement on n'a pas vu les patients au
même stade donc ça fait extrêmement
important d'en avoir conscience
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est que
quand même quand on voit des personnes
qui y sont des scientifiques et qu'une
qui attaquent des de façon tout à fait
irrationnel des publications c'est tout
à fait anormal et vous avez rappelé le
nombre de pays qui traite et anecdotes
j'étais il ya quelques jours avec un
médecin franco marocain et qui exercent
en france et qui me disait mais au début
de la crise mes collègues du maroc ma
plaine pour dire mais qu'est ce que vous
fichez en france nous on traite avec les
toxiques look into se passe très bien et
bon vous savez que le roi du maroc a
aussi présenté les loaded si chloroquine
et le pays gère à gérer la crise
remarquablement bien comme ça et c'est
pas le seul pays en italie les médecins
sont en train de réutiliser sur cette
deuxième phase d'épidémie saisonnières
le cette deuxième épidémie saisonnière
c'est pas une deuxième vague comme on
veut bien dire mais sont des épidémies
saisonnières qui repartent et les
italiens sont en train d'utiliser cette
molécule
donc c'est important de
de comprendre d'essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe parce qu on est dans
quelque chose d'irrationnel aujourd'hui
dans ses bras les jambes je la fais un
bruno mais garvan justement c'est pas un
petit peu contre productif cette
communication à nouveau lancée autour du
professeur raoul qui a déjà eu une
grosse défiance des français envers les
autorités
oui très probablement et c'est pourquoi
c'est toutes ces démarches mon avis sont
peut-être dommageable à terme
je crois que manning manifestement il ya
des plaintes ya un certain nombre de
personnes notamment la société française
de pathologie infectieuse qui a formulé
des plaintes
donc c'est à la justice et notamment la
justice ordinale de se prononcer donc je
ne me substituerait pas aux médecins qui
font partie de cette chambre
disciplinaire
alors c'est vrai que le processeur out
encourent des sanctions personnellement
je ne crois pas qu'on en arrive à ce
stade là c'est je trouve de tout ça
dommageable malgré tout je suis d'accord
effectivement les enseignants doivent
jouir d'une indépendance et d'une
entière liberté d'expression dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions néanmoins
évidemment tout ça doit se faire dans le
respect strict des principes de
tolérance et d'objectivité et donc à
l'ordre de médecins de formuler si
effectivement tout ce qu'a affirmé le
professeur raoul qui était totalement
objectif est basé sur les des arguments
scientifiques
merci à vous bruno mégarde merci
également à vous violaine l'air d'avoir
été avec nous en direct